pueblos de larios no cumplieron esa
promesa de hablar de un gobierno
inclusivo recordemos que esos primeros
días cuando llegaron a favor se
reunieron con ex líderes del anterior
gobierno con hamid karzai con el ex
presidente también con la tuna tula
creando una ilusión en este realmente lo
que ellos querían a pesar de que era un
gobierno liderado por nuestra libanés
traer no solamente diferentes
personalidades de la política sino
también de las diferentes etnias pero lo
que se ha dado cuenta los afganos hoy es
que son ellos su ala más dura todos
integrantes todos veteranos de los
talibanes los que han venido hoy ya
vimos esas protestas que ustedes
mostraban lideradas especialmente por
las mujeres por lo que sucedió en partir
por la influencia paquistaní así que
tendremos que ver realmente cuál va a
ser la reacción de la población
recordemos que también actualizar es un
país muy complejo la mayor parte de la
población vive en áreas rurales las
áreas urbanas en una manera diferente de
ver la situación a esto a estos pueblos
pero maneras creo que va a haber un
impacto porque había una esperanza de
que ellos vinieran con un gobierno por
lo menos más inclusivo del que el que
tiene
catalina este gobierno representado como
un gobierno interino que se perfila en
las próximas semanas
viendo lo que hablaba el portavoz ellos
dicen que todavía tienen la oportunidad
para atraer personas de diferentes
etnias y diferentes lugares del país sin
embargo viendo la importancia que tienen
estos estos líderes nombrados hoy que
tienen una gran importancia dentro el
movimiento talibán hay que recordar que
ellos no son un grupo unido hay
divisiones dentro de dentro de ellos que
tuvieron que haber negociado así que
falta ver hay posiciones que todavía
quedan por llenar por por nombrar pero
si a una primera vista se ubiquen sea
muy difícil estos primeros estos nombres
no acaban anunciados en el día de hoy
vayan a ser cambiados especialmente las
posiciones más importantes falta por
definir quién va a ser el miro es el
líder supremo de esta este emirato
islámico de afganistán así que ya
veremos quién a quien nombra en los
próximos días